All right, good afternoon, everyone.
This is the last session of the
day in this room.
My name is Luis Campus.
I'm a DNAI specialist from the Netherlands,
and I'm here today to share with you
how to build,
manage, and share.
Quickwee dashboards using Amazon
Sage Maker.
I'm gonna be joined on stage by
my colleague Utgars,
product manager for Amazon Sage Maker,
and later on,
Mirko, who leads software engineering
at Nora.
The agenda that we have for you today is gonna be a
packed agenda.
I'm first gonna show you a bit of the map
of the cave
and
lay out the problem and how we
intend to solve and what is that
problem, how do we intend to solve it. Later, Utkar
is gonna
show you what happens behind the scenes and also
an end to end demo
of this integration.
Merkel is gonna come and tell his
story and how his team
is innovating using these technologies.
So let's get started.
Now, one of the books by
Brian Schwartz,
The Paradox of Choice,
talks about this notion that,
in order for someone to be happy,
you need to have options.
But after a certain threshold,
too many options
becomes a hindrance, and creates
decision fatigue,
it becomes a problem.
One thing I can assure you all here today.
The choice to be here in this room
was the right one.
So thank you for your presence.
Now, this problem is not exclusive
to technology in many.
Day to day situations,
you will find decision fatigue
because of this plethora
of options. Too many options.
Well, retail consumers go through
this either in in-store experiences
or online with too many
products, sometimes from the same category,
and being very hard to distinguish
what's the difference between them.
In the entertainment industry, we
have the same, but we have a different problem.
We're seeing more and more.
People replacing
the consumption of selected
content for simple swiping.
And that has to do precisely
with that decision fatigue. I need
to choose content to consume,
but there are too many options.
So I will let the algorithm choose for me.
In companies, in enterprises, the
organizations that have to manage data,
you have a similar, a similar issue
with data coming from different sources,
separate systems,
different technologies as well.
And so,
once you have all these vast amounts of
data that is being sourced.
Being a consumer of that data
becomes a much harder task,
let alone if you need to consume
that data, transform it and then serve
it to someone else.
Navigate through all these options.
Has always the challenge to bridge
these two worlds,
the options that we have, and the consumer.
Now let's go back to the retail
example or entertainment example, if you
wish. Once
you have curated
these options and extracted the metadata
from the products, let's say from an e-commerce
website. Or let's say,
a travel agency that has an
online uh website.
That metadata is being extracted
to create what we call the
filters.
So, uh, I'll give you my personal
example.
Every year, I go on Booking.com,
and I try to select
one of these paradise Islands in the Mediterranean,
and I try to choose
a villa.
In front of the sea
with private, private pool.
And it, I get
so many options. And after that,
I use a 4th filter,
which is my budget, and it goes
down to 0.
So,
this is the experience that still
today a lot of people are grappling
in terms of navigating through the options that
exist. Like
2 decades ago, the last 2 decades, what
we have been doing, and all our customers
have been doing as well,
is trying to
detect the footprint of
these users on their website to
understand their behavior. Also try to
capture their comments,
their reviews, and then feed
a new batch of metadata
in order now, instead of being reactive
and just give filters to the user,
provide them recommendations. So
this is not something new.
Yet,
it's something that a lot of organizations are
still struggling with.
And this is not a technology example, this
is just from a consumer perspective.
Now, let's get a little bit more, let's dive a
little bit deeper.
Let's transport to the enterprise
data world,
where not only you have
several different sources from several different
technologies,
sometimes the same data in
several different forms,
and on the other side,
you have humans, you
have machines,
you have agents, you have software,
you have different sizes and
different shapes of consumers.
The first step
is to curate that
data, extract that data, or
simply zero ETL that
data over to a lake house.
At the lake house, that's exactly
where you're gonna start doing your pre-processing.
See if your data is clean,
if it provides context, but most importantly,
to correlate the data
between all the sources, because now you have
everything in one place.
So far, so good, OK?
Once you have this data, you will
serve it to different communities
inside the organization.
Data scientists will use that to
create models.
But by the way, data scientists, if they wanna
have access to the detail and raw
data, they can always tap into the lake house as
well. Same thing
with BI analysts that will
create dashboards, data stories,
storyboards,
pixel reports, etc.
which by the way, can also tap into the lake
house to get detailed data.
All of these actions
generate
metadata.
And so in order to provide
metadata to an agent, a
piece of software, a human or a machine,
you need to have this catalog.
This catalog will provide a much needed
discovery capability
that users want and need,
as well as the ability to
let them sift through models,
GI applications,
dashboards, etc.
Either an agent
or a consumer.
This is an
issue today.
Because there are two missing links
happening at the same time.
First of all, is
the creation
of a dashboard is disconnected
from the data engineering pipeline,
and what do I mean, what do I mean by this?
I mean that
when a BI analyst needs to create a
dashboard, it needs to first
source the data,
and make sure that data is available
for the tool that it needs.
Or sometimes it may happen that
the tool will bring the pre-processing
into its capabilities, which is a bit of
an overkill if you already pre-processed the
data. This, this happens
a lot.
These tools getting fatter and
fatter in terms of capability. They
do more and more, but
they are not supposed to.
So, where is the data that I need to
build my dashboard, and I
need to move my data.
Turns out that this
hindrance the time it takes
to create a dashboard.
The second issue.
Is the opposite side of the
same coin.
That plethora of options I was talking
about happens for two reasons.
First of all,
the dashboards that are created,
leaving the private workspaces
of the BI analyst,
or sometimes the business user. And
there, there are a lot of duplications,
we know that.
And so what tends to happen is that when someone
needs a dashboard, they don't know where to
find
the exact, maybe someone has built something
similar, so what do they do?
They come back to square one, which
is source the data and build it yet
again. There's
no integrated governance for dashboards,
so we are here today
to solve these two problems.
And solving these two problems
means creating a connected
experience through all the three
stages of the data life cycle,
from collect,
connect,
and consume.
We're gonna talk a little bit about Amazon Sage
Maker and QuickSuite.
But the key topic from, for this
talk today is the integration
between both,
OK. Let's
just Overview
what Amazon Sage Maker is.
SageMaker is,
um, Sage Maker and SageMaker Unified
Studio were launched
in this same place last year, 1 year ago,
as an integrated
uh platform for
all your data, AI and analytics
needs, with 3 main layers.
The first one is the face of the tool.
We call it SageMaker Unified Studio.
Single environment.
And SageMaker Unified Studio
would be used by all these personas, the data scientist, the
engineer,
the business analyst, the Gen AI
developer.
And they all will meet
in one place, which is the Sagemaker
catalog.
Sage maker catalog will provide
them the data discovery capability
that they all need to work together.
They will have projects, they will have domains,
they will have
GI generated metadata. They will have all
these capabilities, glossaries, etc.
that they'll need to find what they need
and to publish their,
their data.
Every person will use a different tool once they are
in AgeMaker in the 5 Studio,
because for instance, a data scientist may
use SageMaker AI
to train and deploy AI models,
while at the same time,
A Gen AI developer can use the Bedrock
IDE to create their custom Gen AI
applications. A dead engineer
may prepare and integrate their data with
EMR
or even runs or business analysts
or data analysts may run their SQL queries
using Redshift.
So they all will enter through the same door,
but at the end they will use
different capabilities of the tool. So Sage
Maker will integrate natively with
Redshift, with EMR, with Sage Maker AI,
and with Bedrock.
Now we're about to bring a brand
new member to this family.
And that's the BI analyst, which
now can also
start in SageMaker,
use the catalog
and solve those two issues that
we were talking about. This means
that in the catalog now,
Side by side with data,
models, and G AI applications,
there will be
dashboards as well.
You will still have the horizontal capabilities
of Sage maker catalog
of data lineage,
integrated data quality
from good data quality.
You also have the pub sub
mechanisms that exist for people
to share data, models and
dashboards amongst them.
I'm not sure if you were
attentive two months ago,
but we've launched,
we, we did a big launch, and that was introducing
Amazon Quick Suite.
Um, it's a tool that
supersedes our previous tool called
Quicksight, our BI tool called Quicksight.
And I'm gonna expand a bit more on what QuickSuite
does.
It has 3 main pillars,
and all of these pillars
are made consistent by something
called spaces. This means that
you can create a space.
Provide data assets inside
that space,
provide files, dashboards, and
something called actions.
And an action is an integrated with
a third party tool.
And once you have all that, you can
create something new, a new
colleague, and that would be your custom
chat agent.
You can specialize a chat
agent inside that space, that
will be an expert on all the things
you've put inside,
OK. So now you can not only
talk with your dashboard,
you can also have a specialist that
knows about that.
And most of the times, this represents
a big advancement in people that are already
working together.
Now, QuickSuite is comprised
of several different tools, and I'm gonna very
quickly skim skim through through them, and
then we're gonna see how the integration works.
First of them is Quick Index that will allow
through an extensive list
of connectors to connect
QuickSuite to a plethora
of
external sources from SharePoint
to Salesforce, etc.
The other interesting part would be
quick sight
and quick research. Quicksight
is the tool that you use
to create dashboards, you use to create
uh storyboards, you use to create
pixel
perfect reports.
And quick research.
We have been using internally at AWS
and it's a game changer.
You will provide
an input in terms of natural language,
you will provide the spaces that you
have created,
and you will toggle something,
go to the web or don't.
And it will create
the topics of a research report you would
like to create.
And after that, of course, you will be able
to um customize
your, your own
research paper.
The automation
inside Quick Suite is done through the use of
Quick flows, so you will create several different
flows. And in order for those flows to
connect with the tools, you will have
quick automate. Automate will be where you
create those actions, where you connect
to, to that external sources, Salesforce
and SharePoint and uh
and whatever tool you use, for instance, for
CRM.
Now, this is where
all of these users will work together
inside QuickSuite,
and the option of the dashboards, it's
where the BI analyst will start,
right? Wrong,
because the BI analyst needs
first
to source the data,
needs to understand where the data is.
So let's layer all these tools that I've talked
about on top of this diagram and
see how does this works. So of course, the
first one,
it's easy.
Lake house is Sagemaker Lake House.
The second one would be the experience
of unified studio would be
the same, both for the builder and
publisher persona, but also for the consumer
or the agent.
And they will all meet in the catalog
as um the metadata
catalog. They will all these um
teams together.
Once QuickSuite comes into play,
this means that
it will be acceptable that
the same catalog will provide
the data assets
for the users of QuickSuite to start
working. And that's what we're going to explore in this
session.
Because once you do that, you're gonna have a
governed
uh or data governance across
your dashboard experience as well.
This means that once,
um,
me, for instance, I'm a BI analyst,
Lewis connects, enters, subscribes
to this table that is called
customer churn data.
Now I have access to that through a project.
I want to create a dashboard.
So where do I start?
I just click on open
in Quick Sweet.
That's it.
In the back,
Amazon Sage maker will take
care
of all that integration. You don't
need to move data,
you don't need to integrate tools.
You will land in Quick Suite with
that data asset
immediately available to create a data
analysis which will result in a dashboard.
And once you create that dashboard,
the dashboard will become cataloged
automatically back in Sage Maker catalog.
How cool is that?
Yes,
OK. Well, to
show you how all this magic works
in the background,
let me call on stage my colleague Utkash.
Thank you. Well,
thank you so much, Louis.
So, Lewis talked about how Amazon
Sage Maker and QuickSuite together
help you simplify the end to end analytics
journey.
Now, let's explore a real-life use case
uh to see how it works in practice.
A data analyst has been asked to explore
whether customer churn interactions have
an impact on.
Customer churn.
So, it sounds like a simple problem at first,
but where do you even begin?
Your churn data might live in a redshift
data warehouse,
managed by a different team.
Your customer support data might
be in Glue data catalog in a
completely different account,
um, with no business context at all.
So, first of all, how do you find this
data? And once you find
this data, how do you get access to this
data? How do you understand this data with
business context?
And then how do you analyze and visualize this
data using the tools of your choice?
SageMaker Inf Studio and QuickSuite help you do all of that in
a single streamlined Gov workflow
that Lewis talked about,
and that is exactly what we'll explore in this demo.
We'll start with data discovery. We'll show you
how you can use the catalog in SageMaker Inf Studio
to find data that you may not even have access
to. We will then show you how you can
access that data in a self-service
manner. We will show you how you can analyze
that data using some of the tools
built in within SageMaker Unified Studio.
And then once you have analyzed your data, how
you can transition into QuickSuite
so that you can visualize that data
and build a dashboard and once you have built
that dashboard,
how you can catalog and share that data
so that the insights that you have generated
do not just simply
exist in a silo within your own PI personal PI workspace.
Now, before we start, let's take a look at
the 3 personas who will be part of this demo.
First, we have Daniel, who is a data analyst,
and his responsibility is
to turn raw data into meaningful insights.
Then we have
John, who is
Uh, who is a business business user. He
heads the customer support team, and he's
looking to understand
how does the customer support interactions of his
team impact the customer chart.
And finally we have Priya, who is
a data owner. She owns the uh
data in the catalog, and she
is responsible for managing
access to the data that she owns.
All right, so with that, let's jump into the
demo and see how the data analyst
can start with data discovery.
So here we are in Sagemaker Unified studio.
We are logged in as Daniel, who is our data analyst.
He's in this churn analysis project, and if
you go to the data page,
you can see that Daniel already has
access to some of the data.
For example, he has access to this
churn labels.
He can see it's technical metadata, like
which account does the data exist in,
he can look at the columns, he can look at the sample
data to understand how the data looks like.
But what he does not have is
access to any data related to
customer support metrics. So let's see if
he can find this data in the catalog.
So he starts by typing in the search bar, and
immediately he can start seeing some search results.
So let's look at the first
search result.
It's a table called Support chat metrics. It's
a table in the Glue Data catalog.
You can see that there is already some business context
about this table.
He can also see some technical metadata, like
where does this table exist, which account,
what is the S3 location of this table.
And he can see some other information like the ownership,
like who is the owner
of this data.
So in case if he needs to reach out to the owner, he can do that.
On the schema tab, he can see all of the columns,
he can see its data types,
and he can see the descriptions. It's not just
cryptic column names, but a lot of business
context. So after all of
this business context,
Daniel realizes that this is the dataset he needs for
his analysis.
But how does he get access?
All he has to do is just hit the subscribe button.
Provide a reason for why he needs access.
And that's it.
He can submit the request.
Now at this point, this request goes to
the owner of the data,
who is Priya in this case.
So let's take a look at how Priya's experience would look like.
We are again in Sagemaker Unified Studio, logged
in as Priya this time,
and if we go to the subscription request page,
we can see that there's,
there are a couple of pending requests.
Priya can open one of the requests, she
can see who, who has requested
access for what data, for what purpose.
And she can choose whether she wants to approve with full
access, which means,
uh, Daniel gets access to the full table,
and she can just simply approve the request.
Now what happens at this point is once
the request is approved,
Daniel should be able to access the data,
but to be able to do that.
We do a lot of orchestration behind the scenes.
For example, when
this request is approved, Sagemaker goes into
the underlying data source, which in this case is,
uh, the table is in Glue data catalog. So
Sagemaker goes into Lake formation, which is
used to manage the permissions on Glue data catalog
and creates a grant on behalf of Priya.
And what that means is once that grant is created,
Daniel would be able to access the data.
So let's go back to Daniel's project.
And if we go to the assets page,
You will see that under subscribed data.
There's an asset.
The same asset that Daniel subscribed to, and it
shows up as accessible.
Just to confirm that Daniel can actually
access it, let's go to the data page,
and you can see that the same table also shows
up under
the Data Explorer.
Daniel can access it.
Great, so let's take
a pause and revisit our demo flow. So far
what we have seen
is how Daniel was able to discover new data
that he originally did not have access to,
how he was able to understand that data with business context,
and how he was able to request access and
get access to this data
in a self-service manner.
From this point, Daniel can start analyzing
this data. And for this, he's going to
use a built-in query editor within
SageMaker Unified Studio. So let's take a look at
that. He
goes to the query editor.
And he starts exploring the data.
Here he's
writing a SQL query, he executes it,
and
he's basically seeing how the churn rate varies
with CSET score, how does the average sentiment
looks like,
how does the average response time looks like.
Once he has done this exploratory analysis, he
decides to create a table
with all the dimensions and metrics that
he needs
to be able to visualize this data.
So here, he again runs a query to create
that table,
and you can see in the Data Explorer on the left-hand
side that the table is created.
Great. So with that, Daniel is now ready
to visualize this data in QuickS Suite.
Now, before we jump into
Quick Suite, let's first understand how this integration
actually works.
Between Sage Maker and QuickSuite,
right? So,
with this integration, like Louis was saying,
we provide a one-click transition from Sage Maker
to QuickSuite,
so that as a data analyst who is working in SageMaker,
you can go into QuickSuite and analyze,
uh, and visualize the same data that you're able to
access in Sagemaker.
Now to make that happen, we do a lot of orchestration
behind the scenes.
First of all,
any project that you have in Sagemaker.
If that project has Quicksight enabled in it,
we create a behind the scenes, create a folder
in QuickSuite with the same name as the project,
and any data set or dashboards that
you create in QuickSuite
will exist in this folder itself.
Any IM rolls or connections that you have created
in Sagemaker to access the data,
we use the same IM rolls and connections,
the credentials within those connections to create
data sources in QuickSuite. So for example, we create
an Athena data source,
a redshift data source using the same IM roll
and the same connection
so that whatever data you are able to
access as an analyst in Sagemaker,
you can access the same data in QuickSuite
as well. Any
tables that you want to visualize, we can
automatically create a QuickSuite data set
for that table. So when you land in QuickSuite,
you have a data set ready for you.
To visualize. So, you can focus your
energy on visualizing the data rather than
trying to create a data source or go through this
extensive setup.
With this data set,
you create an analysis and then a dashboard
in QuickSuite, which is a standard way of creating
a dashboard,
and once that dashboard is created,
behind the scenes, we automatically
bring that dashboard as an asset in the catalog
in Sagemaker.
And what that means is
from that point you can add more business data,
business business metadata to that dashboard.
And make it discoverable in the catalog so that other
users who do not have access to your dashboard
can find the dashboard. And if they
want to use the insights that you have generated,
they can do that.
And finally, we make sure that the
membership, members in the project are always in sync
with the members in the folder in QuickSuite. So
anytime you add a member to the project or
remove a member from the project,
we make sure that
the same members are also added and removed from
the folder as well.
Great. So with that understanding.
Let's see how
Daniel can go from sage maker to quick suite.
So he simply chooses this option to open in Quick Suite.
And we open QuickSuite in a new browser
tab, and he lands on this data set in QuickSuite,
which is automatically created for him.
It's the same
with the same name as the table that he needs
to visualize.
And now all he needs to do is just simply use this
data set
in an analysis.
He adds this, you know, he creates an analysis
using this data set.
Now he wants to add
A new calculated field for churn rate.
So he adds a calculated field. He describes
how the churn rate should be calculated in natural language,
and QuickSweet is able to figure out the right formula for
him. All he has to do is just add this.
New field to his analysis.
Now he creates a few charts
to understand how
the churn rate
varies with support metrics.
So here he's creating a chart to
see how CSAT score impacts churn
rate, and he can see that as the CSAT
score is lower, the churn rate is higher.
Now he also wants to see
how the sentiment in the chart impact the
churn rate.
And this time instead of creating a chart chart
manually, he describes it in natural language.
And QuickSuite is able to create the right chart
for him. All he has to do is add this chart
to his analysis.
So you can see how easy it is
to go from
Sagemaker to come to QuickSuite and start building
your analysis and charts.
Now, after doing all of this ad hoc analysis,
Daniel realizes that
support, customer support interactions are really impacting
the customer churn and it's really important to monitor
these metrics on a regular basis.
So he goes and
creates some more beautiful charts like
these. Now I won't go into
um
showing you how exactly he built those charts, but I guess
you get the point.
But once he has built this nice
analysis with all these beautiful charts,
he wants to make these charts available to other users,
and for that, he can simply publish this
analysis as a dashboard.
He gives it a name.
He enables Q&A. I'm gonna talk
about the Q&A feature in a minute.
And that's it. He can publish this dashboard,
which means now he can start
sharing and cataloging this dashboard.
So let's come back to our demo flow. So far we
have seen how
the analyst was able to discover,
access the data, how he was able
to analyze the data using the query editor,
and how he was able to go into QuickSuite
to visualize that data and build a dashboard.
Now Daniel wants to make
sure that the dashboard that he has built with all
the insights
don't remain in a silo within his own personal BI
workspace. So how can he catalog
this dashboard
and make it discoverable in the catalog?
So let's take a look at that.
So, Daniel is back to his project in Sagemaker.
He's at exactly at the same place where he
left before
moving to Quick Suite.
And now if he goes to the assets page.
You will notice that
there is
an asset called Churn Dashboard automatically
created for him. He did not have to do
anything to create this asset in the catalog. It's automatically
registered,
and from this point he can open this
asset.
You will see that.
A bunch of information about this dashboard is automatically
imported over from QuickSuite, like it's
URL, which QuickSuite account does it exist in.
And on top of that, he can start adding business metadata.
So as an example,
he is adding.
A description to this dashboard.
And once he is done adding this business metadata.
He can make this dashboard discoverable for others
by simply publishing it to the catalog.
And once he's published it, you will see
that if we start searching in the catalog
search bar.
This dashboard will start showing up in the search results,
which means any user who has access to Sagemaker
can now find this dashboard.
Another thing that uh Daniel can do here
is that he can also start sharing this dashboard
with the other users and groups in the organization
from within the catalog itself. He does not have
to necessarily go into QuickSuite to do that.
So here you will see that he's sharing this
dashboard with a business user.
He, he can uh choose to share it with users
or groups, but in this case, he's sharing it with a user,
and once he has shared this dashboard,
again, Sagemaker goes into the
underlying service, which is QuickSuite in this case,
and manages the permissions on the dashboard so that this
business user
can access the dashboard.
So let's see how the
experience of a business user looks like.
So the business user, of course,
can access the dashboard, but it's not just that
he can access the dashboard, they can also
ask questions and dive deeper
into this analysis by asking questions
in natural language.
So in this case, they're asking, how does
the response time impact churn rate,
and Sagemaker can do all the analysis
behind the scenes using the same data that's used to
build the dashboard.
And come up with some charts,
as well as a natural language description,
explaining how
the average, uh, how the churn rate uh
is impacted by the response time.
Great, so that concludes the demo. We saw in
this demo how
uh data analysts can go from
having no access to data to
finding the data,
understanding it with business context, and getting access to that
data in a self-service manner,
and analyzing that data and visualizing
it, and finally
cataloging and sharing their insights in the catalog.
Now with that, I'm going to hand over the mic to
Mirco Buholzer,
VP of Natera.
To share how NEra is using these two services
to drive innovation.
Thank you, Akash.
Thank you for being here. Um, I'm gonna
represent NoEra here for, um,
this functionality. It was great to partner
with, um, AWS to actually get this
implemented.
Um, early on we like saw this
as something we really wanted to have in
our, um, data analysis environments
and with this
integration of data and visualizations
into one environment,
um, it, uh, really helped us
quite a bit to, to like, um, get
the value of our tools up and running,
and we're gonna talk about a little bit more
on, um, how we're using this
and why this is quite important for,
for us.
So, NTEra was founded in 2004,
um, pioneering
the cell-free DNA,
uh,
technology, and we're basically building
non-invasive, um, tests
which can give us,
uh, critical information about health
conditions early on,
uh, in the journey of, uh,
many, many patients.
Um, we have labs in
the San Francisco Bay Area as well as in
Austin, Texas.
And it's uh really
key for us on a mission
to help as many patients as
we can.
So with that, we can aim at
transforming the management of
disease worldwide and as you
can see from the statement, this is
kinda like a very moonshot type
uh um activity that we
would like to achieve and with that
we know this is not something which
is uh done within,
within a month or two, right?
Um, we have quite a bit
of, uh, tests that we're actually
already providing from women's health all
the way, um, to oncology
and organ health and where we have a
deep portfolio of tests that we're providing
to our patients.
Um, the key part here is we want
to expand and, uh,
enhance those tests as
quick as possible. So for us it's very
important to be able to iterate very
fast and have, uh, a quick innovation
cycle.
Uh, across our portfolio
and uh being able to basically bring
new tests to market very quickly.
So as you can see, um, the
innovation is not just
around,
uh, being able to, uh,
do the scientific innovation itself,
but then also being able to, uh,
leverage the data that we have from
all the other different tests that we're already
doing and with that, um, introducing
new tests. So.
Uh, alone
in the 5 last years
we basically brought to market 5 tests,
uh, 8 tests,
and, uh, we're able to like
expand our portfolio quite a bit.
Um, for us,
scalability is a key component.
Signathera is one of the fastest growing,
uh, genomic diagnostic tests in
the world,
and with that we need to have a good infrastructure,
um, to be able to actually handle
all that.
So, going a little bit back to
like the, the key aspects in
regards to combining data with visualization,
um,
the journey of many companies basically
starts
probably with um
applications having siloed data
and analytics tools within each of
the applications.
Um,
once that
stage is kind like past, we are moving
into kind of like an area where a
lot of companies are basically building
centralized analytics, um,
teams,
and with that we're introducing kind of like a
bottleneck in the
organization where, um, we're
like trying to have one
team solve all the answers
for everyone else, um.
So what we can like moved into is
really into like a data mesh model,
which allows us to everyone collaborating
very distributed,
um, very uh self-serve
model uh where we use unified studio
and have the ability to really contribute,
um, all the data products and assets
to that platform.
Um. So for example
here we have a data domain on
the lab side which is combining
all the. Uh, the
DNA data, the clinical data,
um, as well as some of the instrument
and, and, um, execution
and operations data, uh,
onto the platform and moving
that and allowing everyone else
to, to use that data
across the organization.
So this includes obviously
like interpretation, but then all the way
to
R&D to develop new tests.
A key part from
The data mesh standpoint
is really having
uh the ability for each of the data
domains being uh
separate and independent
um we don't want to have a centralized
uh bottleneck and with that we
wanna make sure
that the um the
different teams are able to like manage
their data on their own.
This has a big disadvantage where we want to
make sure that we have governance,
we have security,
we have um access rights,
we know where the data is, we don't copy
data around
so to mitigate that
we basically wanna have a centralized
place
uh with unified studio to
kind of like collaborate around the data
and being able to do that um
for the full team
and till now that was mostly.
Uh, around like the analytics
person, but it wasn't really around visualization.
So, with this new functionality,
we are now able to
like um centralize as
including the visualization aspects
and the dashboards as well.
Um, obviously on the platform itself, I
can use all the different tools, right, which are
available. So,
uh, the, the SQL UI,
the, uh, Jupiter notebooks,
um, I can go into MLOps and
so on. I have all that capability
at my fingertip and can use that,
uh, but I'm also now
able to bring in the actual business user
and the, the visual aspects,
um, and can combine all that together.
What we were doing initially when we
introduced this was really
making sure we're moving the data
responsibility to the different
applications.
Um, a key aspect,
um, that you see in many times
with
analytics organizations is that
they start to collect just copy databases
over into the analytics environment
and then you have the central team trying to
make sense out of it.
Um. What we changed
here is really
making sure that um data is
a first-class citizen within the
application teams where they define the schema,
where they define the actual um
uh shape of the data that we want to publish
and uh are able to like
own that similar to an API or
something else within the application
where you really have a defined way and how
you push that into.
The data mesh.
So we're using like the
application which generates um events
uh which are clearly formatted
and then move them into the data mesh.
We have an option for serverless
transformation as well if you want to,
but the goal is really to have the
application on the shape and we don't
have to do a lot of transformation anymore.
So everything is basically done on an
application level and we just ingested
into the data mesh and have it in the catalog
available.
So, the other big question
that we had was really how do we organize
um our infrastructure
uh with QuickSuite and
Unified Studio and how
do we um kinda make
this an an ability to
really self-serve across the
organization. Um,
obviously since
looking at a couple of the items that we
already saw, you might see that
we really wanna have small
independent teams
being able to run,
uh, on their own pace and with
that we decided to
have lab domains we, we
decided to have like a commercial domain,
we have a clinical domain where each
of those domains basically own
certain aspects of um
the data.
And manage their own catalog
and the uh and and uh
visualizations,
but then combined have a company-wide
uh implementation
where we can like share the, the
golden data set as well as
the golden visualizations um
that can be accessed everywhere.
With this, we don't really have to copy data,
so the information is basically
just accessed directly in the domain.
Um, so it's very transparent.
Obviously, you can make the argument you wanna have
everything in one account,
uh, which is fine too, but I think this
is like uh an approach where we
think the teams are really
independent and can run at their own pace.
So, similar to that, it's kinda like the
question on how do we organize our
teams.
And usually you have like
a technology uh
team which um owns the
application. We mentioned, we are basically pushing
and shaping the data already into the data
mesh, so that's called the application owner.
Um, we have
product owners which really take that data
already, create visualizations,
create metrics,
create, um, insights
where we know what type of
functionality or features we need to
develop based on the insights we
get and have the ability
to really run the application
data driven so that we can develop
the, the, um, have the ability to
really create applications which, which meet.
Uh, the user's requirements and are
valuable.
The same time, obviously you have kind of a domain
owner which makes sure that the different data
is quite coherent across
the different applications,
but with that you generate
high quality data because you're basically
drinking your own champagne, um,
and are making sure that the data
that is coming in
meets the metrics that you want to
be able to
um develop your application.
Um. This,
this like model creates
high
quality data which then can be used
by the business users.
So on the business side, obviously they might
have similar or different metrics.
Uh, they probably look across different
applications as well,
um, and combine some of this.
Uh, so you have kind of analysts
doing this, combining some of the data sources,
maybe creating new, um, data assets,
um, and visualizations from it.
Um, and is able to really
work independently on that level.
And then obviously
sometimes you have like the business users come in
and say, oh, by the way, I have this
idea. Can you give me some data around
it? That's when the data scientist
can just run
on its own, create a Jupiter notebook,
run the analysis, and come back with
like a validation, um.
So, the business side really is
like independent as well.
They usually have very small analytics
teams within the business organization
and are able to just leverage
the, the infrastructure that was already built,
uh, from the technology
organization. Um,
there might be some requests when some
data is missing, but in general, the
goal is really to have those two
teams being able to run
independently.
So here
kinda like showing some of those visualizations
that have been built,
um, our lab ops team
together with our technology
organization, um, obviously has
like all the
uh clinical metrics,
um,
the execution metrics, and so on,
but they
really wanted to have like a
shop floor
level instrument level visualization
and insight.
Um, of what's going on with
each of the instruments.
So not just like,
um, test metrics, but
really instrument metrics.
Um, this allows them to
look at utilization, uh,
allows them to look at
Uh, maintenance windows that
when or predict certain maintenance,
uh, requests as well
and have that basically available
directly,
uh, on their end and it
was really
incredible to see them basically do that
as a in a self-serve model.
The other thing that we, they can do
now with that is really
plan demand.
So with the utilization of the different
instruments,
they can now basically go through
kind of like
what if scenarios and they can go
through like planning new lab
space or lab uh
requirements based on the insights
they already get from uh
from the production lab.
Another good example um that we
have here is uh around billing
eligibility.
Uh, a big topic obviously for our
patients. They wanna know if their insurance company
is actually paying for the test or what,
what they need to pay on their out of pocket.
Um, so,
we worked closely together with
the business team, the billing team, RCM
team here in this case,
um, together with technology, kind
like having 3 in a box
where they're able to take
the data that is coming. In from
the different eligibility responses
and then optimizing
uh the rules and the executions
to to get high
fully automated uh billing eligibility
responses back from from our vendors.
So we can see we're close to like
80% fully automated uh
where we're getting kinda like um eligibility
responses directly uh from
from our system and
believe me that wasn't that wasn't at 80%
when we started so it was really
great to see the collaboration between
the different um teams
to kinda get up to that, uh, level.
All right. So,
key insights really for us
um is creating reusable
components within
uh the organization where not
everyone has to recreate everything
from scratch.
So, be it uh basically starting with
um data assets or data products
that we have in the organization, being able
to share that in the catalog, being able
to reuse that across
the organization.
Um, is a, is a big advantage
and now with the integration into Quicksight
and QuickSuite, um, we have
the ability now, um, to
also have dashboards with it.
Um, a lot of times some
of our business users just created their whole
catalog of own dashboards,
uh, which weren't shared across the
organization. And
then the other part is really the distributed
data ownership, um, so having
the ability to have small teams
run on their own pace,
being able to, uh, innovate, be
able to have quick answers
and have the ability to, um,
uh, get back to the business owners,
um, in a good way is, is
like a key aspect that we now
have and, um, allows us,
um, to really walk and
run fast.
And obviously all of this is
kind of the
the platform that we need
for our Gen AI
uh journey that we're going through,
um, I mean you,
you, it's all great to
have agents and everything else
running if you don't really know and
have a good,
um, uh, data foundation,
you're not gonna be able to get the results that
you want.
So with this we're basically able to combine
all of that.
All right, that's it from my end,
uh, handing it over to uh Luis.
got. Just
wrapping it up. So I would like to thank your
presence here today.
Wish you a rest of a good
week. If you enjoy this
session, please give us 5 stars
in the app.